what's going on reject nation Greg
al-baqir and John here today's a good
day to die
that's for Flatliners with today's happy
deathday a film presented by blumgum
house production and distributed by
Universal mm-hmm they are a good
collaborative team seems like yeah yeah
they've done a lot I got obviously the
other scream and a long standing right
at the 13 the original Texas Chainsaw
Massacre UNITA Living Dead that we kneel
our movies and he knows the company word
I got a copy of our resume on every
surface of my yeah you have a dimension
bill did a great job of splitting it is
on fire right now that would be Asylum
making the go home just to check this
out okay you're cleaning two women yeah
a for your fans
and a little beyond can be you should
push the wire next time super helpful
don't wait to release me
[Music]
[Music]
okay I know they didn't make any
chemical staff awarness here we can live
in my mind you Smith you a little [ __ ]
happy birthday I've already okay
[Music]
assuming that I believe any of this is
even possible framework carline who
asked you
you have unlimited my watch limited
opportunities to solve around where they
keep dying it's like figure as we might
color it you want to live to see
tomorrow right
whoever's killing you noses you weren't
there
same insane times holy because times off
mention food you should be dead
you realized the same thing over and
over again and sees me where we are
[Music]
Wow
interesting I like that the groundhog
days has become its own genre now let me
get sci-fi Groundhog Day with inch
tomorrow horror Groundhog Day with
happiness and something tells me the
trailer was really trying to amp up the
horror a lot more than I feel like it's
gonna be a lot more fun than what its
leading on yeah I feel like it'll be
more in town with the first like thirty
seconds of the trailer that will be for
that solid minute of pure terror yes
because I don't think it'll work if it
was just like alternating so much Gary I
feel like it has to be a horror comedy
yeah that's pretty much whenever we run
on Facebook a few times it in and that's
what pretty much everybody has kind of
picked up and I don't know what the
truth is actually I just discovered that
this movie exists yesterday yeah that's
kind of the vibe I was getting off the
front end of the trailer to sort of like
it's gotta at least dip in and out of
for accompanying Chris Landon the
director I know be directed Paranormal
Activity the marked ones which is one of
my favorites in that series and that had
a lot of humor in it so I think he can
balance it for sure
yeah yeah yeah so we're some like
Disturbia you said all right heroes
turnout was another that wasn't a horror
movies like thriller with a lot humor in
it rear window with a you know with
quinoa de xt3 I remember laughing a lot
when I watched it yeah yeah it's as
likable it's got a likable I'm you know
yeah cuz this is I mean anytime you do
Groundhog Day scenario you got to have
some comedy infused in it and it's just
like the way the way the vibe is from
like the weight of personalities of all
these characters are behaving I'm sure
there'll be a lot more comedy infusing
the trailers actually letting on I think
because it's Blum house and horrors and
Helmand and like they're coming off of
them like get out they're really trying
to market app abduct terror vibe I have
very little doubt this film will suck
honestly this looks like it's a pretty
good film oh okay very little bit wait
how did I say it I have very little
doubt this film will suck like no doubt
this is gosh you said that wrong and I
have doubt that I down the Schism that's
how I should have said it yeah if only
Groundhog Day was momentary hahaha
dystrophy for living area name 40
revving the same 40 seconds over over
check it out of it I mean I don't really
feel like this would be really
complicated for her to figure out who's
trying to kill her though that's the one
thing I'm thinking about this whole
concept is I don't know if guys they
could set it up you know she could
easily do something in a specific way to
like bring other people in the room with
her or like play everything out exactly
and bring someone in the room with her
but and then again types of premises can
tend to impress me when you never know
like because what end of tomorrow does
it was cool is like it took things that
you were thinking of and that it showed
them to have at least a movie like this
has the potential to go well why does
she do that and I'm sure one day yeah
yeah yeah this is a premise yet I feel
like with enough attention is you can
you can nail it in a pretty flavorful
way I know a lot of the reactions we've
gotten on Facebook haven't been terrific
probably seeing this especially on the
heels of that like it looks it drew me
in like it looks kind of cool and quirky
I'm curious about the tone and I feel
like they'll probably be able to kind of
nicely blend in and out of like humorous
moments and some stuff that's pretty
yeah at least from that wonderful
activity movie that I saw it is I
thought that was one of the best ones
for that reason you know I feel like
this guy can definitely handle that
amount of tone I mean I like right when
the trailer is done my very first
impression was it's probably a
misleading trailer in terms of its tone
and that's why I like I feel like you
get a lot of like small taste like
mostly horror but then it's there's that
kind of hokey stuff at the beginning
that is like the her walking around like
doing a by her man and Walker 1980 and
stuff like
even when she gets killed in the car she
goes oh yeah it's like even though aces
are spawning to the death she's getting
kind of used to being killed in yeah
yeah little glimpses of her like there
are times in like earlier on in the
trailer where she looks really terrible
and then there are like like she's the
this is all sinking and then there are
times later on where it doesn't look
like she's sort of used to this it kind
of looks like a spoof on this trope oh
yeah like you know even though even the
friend you're gonna have that one person
who tells you how you can take advantage
yeah yeah I don't think Groundhog Day
has really like show the nails that do
it ever have that one character who will
tell you you know like this is cheap I
think that's the byproduct of us getting
tired of the trope that like nobody
believes you okay you got somebody we
had and now we get that now we're shoes
you know make it cool don't you [ __ ]
unearthing - it's coming out on
Halloween and it looks like a good movie
to watch around Halloween yeah I mean a
insidious four got pushed back not
because of this but like that movie got
pushed back I think this is the BH
Halloween movie from what I can gather
oh yeah if Blum House is like king of
horror right now if it has the phenomena
for and then this is their move one of
their movies and are they having more
than just one movie i know i don't know
i don't i'm not good completely right
now this was a slate of eh is
frontrunner brother that are always for
holloway today yeah i am very surprised
that this movie wasn't good yeah it
looks like I definitely think it's got
all the potential in the world you know
like nothing about this trailer makes a
go photo you know things happen but I
think it could be a pretty sweet little
little spooked fest you gotta work your
way up the Blum House plan or so we get
a trailer advice to start cutting their
trailer ya know he'd sell it and then
we'll find out that and like action to
the trailer you will do reactions to
every edit so like you can watch it grow
over time and we'll get to spoiler
reviews in the trailers in it I wish we
didn't give away so much in this street
here you know like I feel like you know
now we've
showing you the whole movies we
basically have subscribe is a railroader
eject click that notification bell - on
Humphrey on Twitter and into the social
media manager of balaam house in case
you haven't caught on and also make sure
to check out our patreon what is this
thumbnail that's pointing at Chris
Pratt's past 10 improvised moments that
were forced to keep and it's a thumbnail
of Chris Pratt's ABS honor okay might be
just the ending for my past I got a real
good subverts and rewards and video
content thank you